i'm in a dessert because i want to get
one more game
after this one
i also want to play a stafford
oh no stafford coming
okay
maybe vienna
be on the gamut coming
yeah against knight c3 you can't play
stafford
you can't play jalalabad
the fun openings don't really work
the d3 is already probably a little bit
questionable the blocks in the bishop
the main moves are either f4
or bishop c4
oh bishop e3
okay i'll take and play d5
just trying to go for a more open
position what opening will i recommend
against d4
yeah there's a lot of choices against d4
grunfeld greenfield is like very very
reputable
but at the sub
sub 2000 level if you're playing
grunfeld
it's more about just knowing ideas and
where to place your pieces
and you shouldn't worry too much about
the
main line theory
um
yeah there's three attackers now on d5
which is bishop e6 there's also bishop
g4
there's also c6
i do have to move faster than the
previous game
yeah green foul king's indian is
maybe somewhat closely related
there's uh queen's gap decline which is
more classical
i like to play
or slav or semi-slav
or bononi
or england gambit
okay
the center is very tense
the problem for white these pieces are
not developed
all my minor pieces are developed so
whatever happens in the center
it should be
better for black
yeah there's still initiative too
if e4 i can take on d4
counter attacking the queen attacking
this
queen h4 looming
[Music]
defending everything
i have this move or this move
let me go play this move
now king d1 i play this and win the
queen
if king f2 i probably still play this
and then there's a funny line queen g7
queen d4
king g3
and then queenside castling
that's not happening
yeah no mercy here
i think this is a pretty safe pre-move
too slow to pre-move though
okay let's go for the kill
idea queen e3
or queen e4
i'm calculating checkmate
i was actually calculating a funnier
line
uh let's say h3
here here here
here here here and then asking queen's
eye with mate
was kind of what i was hoping for
as me because the knights pinned so i
can't block
uh
but this was also fun
okay let's move on
almost perfect game i made one
inaccuracy
bishop e6 was dubious
okay
back to tournament
oh so i wanted to show the
it's only chasse you can click into
any time format
and
[Music]
i still need to lower my deviation thing
okay morph is working
i'll play e4
i think again i'll play super
aggressively
oh i'll play the
i'll play the two nights attack
i do have a recent video how to crush
the caro khan
in which i recommend this line
um
actually didn't cover the specific
move order in the video
um the queen here very typical for lack
to play knife six and just for trade the
knights
or g6 and
team caddo
in general these these positions are a
bit more solid and
um
very positional
okay
black not falling for my
deviousness
i tried though had to try it i was
writing made in one for
those not aware
let's go
love london
oh i love you too
brings keith
i mean i could go for a5 here
i have to chase the knight back to d7
interesting
let's lift the rook
and this is still playable
ah there goes my hopes and dreams of
smother mating
weirdly enough i think it's already like
um
is it winning
there's one move for black yeah knight
d5
i felt close to winning i'll play queen
g3
now threatening b7
i don't show this uh
this variation in my crush the caro khan
video
um how to develop maybe just d4
c4 someday
bishop d3
kudos to block for not getting mated
after five moves
but kudos to me for
being persistent and
getting a winning position
ooh
um
i had the idea of this and this but
it doesn't work at all
i could take the rook i'll take the rook
and then take the pawn
there's queen e4 bishop e3
oh
no you're a queen
mate next oh almost mate
okay no mercy here
running maiden one now
ooh
the spike check
you duck
this is absolutely quackalicious
also quack also hi
also quack
also checkmate
okay that's a fun game
thanks to my opponents
and black actually played like a very
standard line
um
how many people have gotten mated here
wow 61 people
one sad or two sad souls playing bishop
c4
okay let's go back
so i'm trying to work my way up
i'll be there i'm trying to get in as
many games as possible
in the last 10 minutes of this arena
oh stafford gamma time
i'm still insisting
please
this is similar to my previous game
where the knight was here and white
played bishop c3
bishop e3
oh okay
yeah we might actually be getting a
stafford here
question if i have recommendations
against f3 and stafford
yeah taking and playing f3 is uh it's
playable
um
generally like i recommend knight h5
it's out of queen h4 go for f5
and
white is
lacking in development
wait what's the line
the line is this
oh it's been a while since i've looked
at this
after d4 i
think i'm
i forget the move order i'm supposed to
take first
this is like a
it's not a staffer because black or
white didn't take here
but it's a weird gambit line
i've looked at a few times in the past
where i think i'm supposed to take
and then take here and then it's fun
yeah it's kind of like a reverse five
liver
but a little bit different
so i'm basically sacking two knights
this is the first night sack
this is the second night sack
and the point is if king takes like
queen h4
i'll win back at night and the king will
be
a bit naked
wow
oh things are gonna get spicy
white's queen is still hanging and now
the bishop's hanging
and the rook's hanging and the knights
attacked
yes yeah we're de-clothing white's king
side
it's a weird uh
slightly weird metaphor
oh hey john
john pointing out that like the
castling's a legal move
that would be hilarious
i think i just take here
wait what what is this
if i take
i'm trying to count material takes takes
bishop d7
and there's queen here
ah it's so confusing
there's also queen h4 immediately which
is
kind of hilarious
but i think i should be taking
because i win back the night
so it's it's very temporarily equal
material but now i'm down the pawn
so i have a choice between king f8
or bishop d7
i was just looking at queen takes d5
and then takes and then
there's a funny line
okay let's play this
i might end up blundering both my rooks
a blundering with a winky face
or white might end up plundering the
queen
without a winky face
i'll i'll have to share the funny line
after the game
the line involved takes takes takes here
takes
here takes and then queen d1 mate
but
knight d1 also
is satisfying
okay now
let's try and end the pain
i think it's made in three
looking here one
two
three
such compassion for opponents suffering
yeah trying to be compassionate
for the compassion bits
also hi pam
if you're just joining you're a little
bit late but you're catching
the grand finale of this game
and soon to be this tournament
that was a funny game
uh
yeah it's one of these weird lines
because most people do take and
transpose
but
um i've had this maybe once or twice
before
where
white's supposed to be better but it
does look really scary
and
black scores really well here
so the funny line i was hoping for
oh white's actually doing okay here
i was looking at this line
here here here
aches and then mate
but apparently
white's okay
wait
oh i can play queen f3 oh that would
have been bad
then i lost a rook i could win the rook
maybe it's still interesting
bishop g5 in the end
okay let's get one more game
less than three and a half minutes left
in the tournament
my next game probably won't count for
the tournament
but i'm just trying to win as quickly
as humanly possible
which means i have to move fast
so i have three minutes to win this game
hey it's kind of a fun opening maybe
we'll get another reverse fried liver
ooh
ooh bishop g5 is a good move
still waiting for bishop g5
no my queen
my beautiful queen
oh i wasn't thinking
or was i thinking
technique
okay that's the grand finale
oh
it never gets old
opponent took some time too
the key was to play knight e4 really
quickly
and make it seem like a blunder i guess
thank you levy 999
probably not related to
levi rosman
hello youtube yeah
that's my youtube content for the day
remember to subscribe and like and
comment
i think legal mate type wins are my
favorite